percé le cuir coudre à la main en
quelques gestes les bases de la
maroquinerie
il y a cinq ans ils étaient 300 dans
cette usine l'entreprise espèce connue
pour ses bracelets de montres compte
désormais plus de 1000 salariés
aujourd'hui 20% notre activité est axée
sur l'horlogerie dont on est proche on
est à une trentaine de kilomètres de la
suisse
elle reste de notre activité va
principalement est retourné sur la
maroquinerie est l'accessoire de mode
ici 80 % des salariés sont des femmes
beaucoup ont trouvé une deuxième vie
dans la maroquinerie cette assistante
maternelle agréée donc rien à voir
et c'est en cherchant du travail je
voulais mettre à mon compte dans la
culture de vêtements et j'ai appris que
ici embaucher du coup j'ai tenté ma
chance et sahara et c'est pour moi la
reprise économique dans le luxe a dopé
les commandes
une embellie qui pousse l'entreprise a
recruté elle va embaucher plus de 100
personnes par an pendant trois ans on va
les former en interne de l'entreprise à
travers notre école qui s'appelle
l'école de maroquinerie d'avoudrey et
donc pendant onze à quatorze semaines on
va former ses futurs personnes ces
futurs maroquinier et pour être sûr de
les attirer alors là on arrive dans
notre espace forme et détente
l'entreprise a tout prévu chaque site de
production compte un restaurant moderne
et lumineux ainsi qu'une crèche un
argument de poids pour les jeunes mamans
du coup ça facilite la reprise du
travail aussi parce que dès que
l'annoncé de la grossesse on peut déjà
faire notre demande ici à la crèche on
sait qu'on n'a pas à courir quatre coins
de la ville pour trouver une maman ici
les salaires à l'embauché sont 15%
au-dessus du smic pas encore suffisant
pour lutter avec la suisse voisine très
attractif alors et cs joue sa meilleure
carte
lusine à la campagne et un ciel
économique totalement dégagée